while his teammate be on the side of the
people Smugglers we're on the side of
the British people politics can be a
dirty game they're on the side of the
people traffickers who enriched people's
lives The Grubby tactics the underhand
attacks now it's a labor party accused
of going too far with a tweet that reads
do you think adults convicted of
sexually assaulting children should go
to prison Rishi sunak doesn't outrage
ensued but then came this more of the
same labor doubling down there are
undoubtedly ethical and factual
questions around Labor's tweet not least
the fact that their first tweet relates
back to 2010 when Rishi sinach wasn't
even an MP but they want to be seen as
the party of Law and Order they want us
to be talking about this getting their
message across that the conservatives
are soft on crime it is perhaps an
age-old campaign tactic comparisons have
been made with this controversial moment
this lead of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions Mr
Speaker he spent most of his time
Prosecuting journalism failing to
prosecute Jimmy Savile as far as I can
make up wake up
today Labor faces accusations from their
own side of so-called horrible
disgusting tactics even current front
benches have struggled to defend it
won't be to everybody's uh taste but
what's the important issue here is What
Lies Beneath that which I think will be
of of real importance to your viewers
which is that we do have serious
criminals now in this country almost
almost routinely uh getting uh more
lenient custodial sentences than they
would otherwise do because the system is
creaking at the knees but the party may
just have decided outrage is a price
worth paying to land the message
politicians of all parties make
exaggerated claims in adverts and they
pin blame on the outcomes of policies
that might not really have anything to
do with the particular politician that
they're attacking I'm slightly surprised
about this particular advert because
it's incredibly divisive and you know
you've seen it's already had a trump
style warning on the Tweet which doesn't
which doesn't look good for any
political party gutter tactics or just
the cut and thrust of Politics the tone
will only Harden in the run-up to an
election Sky News